قال رئيس المكتب السياسي لحركه حماس
اسماعيل هنيه ان الحركه تسلمت المقترح
الذي تم تداوله في اجتماع باريس ولفت الى
ان الحركه بصدد دراسته وتقديم ردها عليه
على قاعده ان الاولويه هي لوقف العدوان
على غزه وانسحاب قوات الاحتلال خارج
القطاع كما قال هانيه ان الحركه منفتحه
على مناقشه اي مبادرات او افكار جديه
وعمليه شرط ان تفضي الى وقف العدوان
وايواء اهالي غزه واعاده الاعمار ورفع
الحصار وانجاز عمليه تبادل جديه للاسرى
وثمن هنيه دور قطر ومصر للتوصل الى اتفاق
لوقف اطلاق نار مستدام في غزه على طريق
انهاء العدوان وحث العالم للضغط على
الاحتلال لوقف المجازر وجرائم الحرب بما
في ذلك سياسه التنكيل بحق الفلسطينيين في
الضفه وثمن هنيه موقف مصر المتطابقه مع
الموقف الفلسطيني برفض وجود الاحتلال على
الحدود مع مصر وافشال مخطط التهجير
واستنكر هنيه موقف الولايات المتحده وبعض
الدول الغربيه تجاه الاونور وتعليق
مساهماتها بدل زيادتها كما ابد هنيه تقدير
الحركه لموقف جنوب افريقيا التاريخي في
رفع دعوى بمحكمه العدل الدولي
وانتصارها للشعب الفلسطيني كذلك ابد
اعتزاز حركه حماس بما يجري على جبهات
المقاومه المسانده لغزه من تطورات نوعيه
قال انها تهدف لوقف العدوان ورفع الحصار
كما استنكر هنيه الاعتداءات التي يتعرض
لها لبنان واليمن وسوريا والعراق
والتهديدات المتواصله
لايران
نشير فقط الى الخبر العاجل الذي يظهر على
شاشتنا الان نقلا عن وزاره الصحه في غزه
فان عدد ضحايا الحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع
غزه ارتفع الى
26751 شهيدا
و656
و36 جريحه اذا هذا في احدث بيانات وزاره
التي تتحدث عن حصيله الشهداء والجرحى في
هذه الحرب الاسرائيليه المستمره على غزه
لكن نعود الى تفاصيل تلك الصفقه التي
ناقشها مجلس الحرب في اسرائيل وما جرى في
هذا الاجتماع وما رشح عنه نستطلع كل
التفاصيل مع مراسلتنا من تل ابيب نجوان
سمري
نجوان نعم مريم دعينا نشير الى انه هناك
اهتمام
سياسي واعلامي واسع بالتصريحات الاخيره
لرئيس المكتب السياسي لحركه حماس فيما يخص
ان الحركه تدرس المنحى والصفقه التي تم
تداولها وبحثها في اجتماع باريس يوم امس
الاول لانه منذ يوم امس وقبيل اجتماع مجلس
الحرب وبعد اجتماع مجلس الحرب طيله الوقت
هناك ترقب للرد من حركه حماس على هذه
الصفقه
بحسب ما ورد في وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
فهناك منحى واضح وكانت ربما للمره الاولى
منذ بدايه الحرب يعلن مكتب رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو في بيان من قبله بان
الاجتماع والمداولات في باريس كانت بناءه
ولكن يقول بانه ما زال هناك ربما بعض
الفجوات التي يجب الحديث عنها خلال
مفاوضات الحديث يدور عن منحى وافقت عليه
اسرائيل بشكل مبدئي وهو الهدنه لمده شهر
ونصف الى شهرين يتم خلالها اطلاق سراح نحو
40 الى 45 اسيرا اسرائيليا محتجزا في غزه
مقابل 100 الى 200 اسير فلسطيني لكل اسير
او محتجز اسرائيلي وهناك نوع من تهيئه راي
العام في اسرائيل في الايام الاخيره
الماضيه لبدء تقبل فكره ما يعرف بتبييض
سجون الاحتلال والسجون الاسرائيليه من كل
الاسرى
الفلسطينيين بداخل هذه السجون وفقا لهذه
الصفقه المرحله الاولى منها ستتعلق
بالافراج عن اسرى اي من ممن تبقوا من
الاطفال والنساء
والمسنين وربما ايضا جزء من المصابين
وستنتقل الى مراحل اخرى مرحله ثانيه
ومرحله ثالثه ايضا تتضمن هدى
انسانيه وتصل في نهايه الامر الى الافراج
عن الجنود وايضا جثامين لاسرائيل محتجزين
والتقديرات الاسرائيليه ان هناك نحو 40 من
الجثامين ممن قتلوا في السابع من اكتوبر
او خلال الاسر حتى خلال العمليات التي كان
حااول الجيش الاسرائيلي تخليص وتحرير عدد
من الاسرى الذين قتلوا خلال هذه ال
العمليات هذه هي الصفقه التي يدور الحديث
عنها اسرائيليا العائلات تزيد من الضغط
عائلات الاسرى المحتجزين في غزه ت تزيد
هذا الضغط بعد موجه غضب عارمه عبروا عنها
في اعقاب الخطاب الذي القاه قبل ايام
قليله نتنياهو واتهم هذه العائلات وان
المظاهرات التي يخرجون فيها والحراكات
الاحتجاجيه هي تزيد من مطالب حركه حماس
عمليا هذا ادى الى غضب شديد في اوساط
الشارع الاسرائيلي من قبل العائلات تحديدا
ولكن ايضا من قبل الاف المتضامنين معهم
واتهموا نتنياهو بانه يحاول طيله الوقت
توجيه اصابع الاتهام الى جهات اخرى من
بينها دول الوسطاء وعلى راسهم دوله قطر
وايضا باتجاه العائله ليبرئ نفسه دائما من
انه لا يكترث لقضيه الاسرى ولا يقوم بفعل
كل ما يلزم من اجل التوصل الى ابرام صفقه
تبادل عندما يوجه نتنياهو مثل هذه
الاتهامات
للعائلات والمظاهرات التي والاحتجاجات
التي بداوا ياخذونها منذ بدايه الحرب من
اجل المطالبه بالافراج عن ابنائهم او
عندما يقول بان قطر
يمكنها ممارسه ضغط اكبر فهو عمل يحاول
تصدير ازمه ازمته مع هذا الملف الى اخرين